STEVE: MICHIGAN’S GOVERNOR IS
UNDER FIRE AGAIN FOR  VIOLATING
HER OWN COVID GUIDELINES AGAIN,
AFTER GETTING CAUGHT UNMASKED
DINING OUT, WITH A BUNCH OF
FRIENDS, ABOUT A DOZEN.
THE GOVERNOR RESPONDING IN PART,
"I WENT WITH FRIENDS TO A LOCAL
RESTAURANT, AS MORE PEOPLE
ARRIVED THE TABLES WERE PUSHED
TOGETHER, BECAUSE WE WERE ALL
VACCINATED, WE DIDN’T STOP TO
THINK ABOUT IT.
IN RETROSPECT I SHOULD HAVE
THOUGHT ABOUT IT.
I AM HUMAN.
I MADE A MISTAKE.
I APOLOGIZE.
" FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR BEN
DOMENECH IS HERE, WITH REACTION,
GOOD MORNING TO YOU, BEN.
>> GOOD MORNING TO YOU, PETER,
I TOO AM HUMAN.
STEVE: HOLD IT, MY NAME IS STEVE
YOU’RE THINKING OF THE TALL GUY
AT THE WHITE HOUSE!
>> OH, I’M SO SORRY [LAUGHTER]
STEVE: YOU’RE AS BAD AS SHE IS!
>> I JUST THINK THAT THE ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT IS GOING ON HERE
IS THAT YOU HAVE A GOVERNOR WHO
HAS BEEN
SO VICIFEROUS IN CHIDING HER
PEOPLE, IN UNDERCUTTING THEM, IN
BRINGING THEM DOWN AND GOING
AFTER THEM IN SO MANY DIFFERENT
RESPECTS AND YET, WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THIS , YOU KNOW, SITUATION,
YOU HAVE SOMEONE WHO HAS
REPEATEDLY VIOLATED HER OWN
ORDERS, OR  STRETCHED THEM IN
DIFFERENT WAYS.
YOU SAW THE WHOLE EXPERIENCE
WITH HER HUSBAND GOING, WANTING
TO GO OUT ON A BOAT AND CITE
LING, YOU KNOW, DO YOU KNOW WHO
I AM, EARLIER AND THAT’S WHAT
WE’VE SEEN FROM ALL OF THESE
POLITICIANS THROUGH THIS WHOLE
PROCESS WHERE THEY ARE UNWILLING
TO GRANT GRACE OR  FORGIVENESS
OR  UNDERSTAND HUMANS WHO ARE
GOING TO MAKE MISTAKES OR
VIOLATE RULES IN DIFFERENT
RESPECTS.
INSTEAD THEY GO AFTER THEM
HAMMER AND TONGS AND YET WANT A
DIFFERENT STANDARD FOR
THEMSELVES.
STEVE: SURE THIS LATEST INSTANCE
WHERE SHE BROKE HER OWN RULES
THERE WERE ABOUT A DOZEN PEOPLE.
THE RULES ARE SIX PEOPLE OR
FEWER AT TABLES, THEY PUT THREE
OR  FOUR TABLES TOGETHER,
DISTANCES OF SIX FEET BETWEEN
TABLES, INDOOR CAPACITY AT 50%
OR  100 PEOPLE, ON AND ON, AND
YOU LOOK AT IT AND YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU MENTIONED HER HUSBAND AND OF
COURSE, IN JUNE OF 2020 SHE
JOINED THE GEORGE FLOYD PROTEST,
VIOLATED HER OWN SOCIAL
DISTANCING RULE, REPUBLICANS
CALLED FOR INVESTIGATIONS INTO
HER HANDLING OF THE NURSING HOME
S, TOP AID TRAVELED TO
FLORIDA FOR SPRING BREAK AFTER
BEING TOLD DON’T DO THAT.
SHE WENT ON A PRIVATE PLANE TO
VISIT HER FATHER AND THEN THE
LATEST THING IS SHE VIOLATED
IT AT THE LANDSHARK BAR.
BUT BEN, SHE’S A POLITICIAN.
DOES ANYBODY REALLY EXPECT HER
TO FOLLOW HER OWN RULES?
COME ON!
>> WELL OF COURSE.
I MEAN, YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY,
POLITICIANS ARE BETTER THAN THE
REST OF US.
THAT’S THE THING THAT WE ALL
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND.
YOU KNOW, THEY ARE OUR RULING
CLASS, OUR ELITE AND SO THE
RULES SHOULDN’T APPLY TO
THEM.
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET  AWAY
WITH ALL MANNER OF THINGS,
THAT’S WHAT WE LEARNED DURING
THE ENTIRE HUNTER BIDEN
EXPERIENCE THAT YOU DON’T EVEN
ACTUALLY HAVE TO BE A POLITICIAN
YOU CAN JUST BE RELATED TO ONE
AND THEN THE RULES JUST DON’T
APPLY TO YOU.
IN THIS CASE, THOUGH, I THINK
SERIOUSLY LOOKING BACK AT THE
WAY THAT THIS PANDEMIC WAS
TREATED THESE LOCKDOWNS WERE
TREATED NOT JUST BY WHITMER BUT
BY GAVIN NEWSOM, BY SO MANY
DIFFERENT OFFICIALS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, WE’VE SEEN THESE
REPEATED VIOLATIONS OF THE RULES
THAT THEY’VE SETUP FOR US AND MY
RESPONSE TO THAT IS, WE
SHOULDN’T HAVE THE ABILITY OF
THESE POLITICIANS THAT TO SETUP
THESE RULES IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THEIR EMERGENCY POWERS TURN OUT
TO BE A LOT MORE POWERFUL THAN I
THINK ALL OF US REALLY EXPECTED
THEM TO BE, AND THEIR ABILITY TO
CRACKDOWN ON AMERICAN CITIZENS,
AND TAKE TAKEAWAY THEIR FREEDOMS
QUICKLY, TURNED OUT TO BE MORE
SIGNIFICANT THAN WE THOUGHT IN
THE FIRST PLACE THAT’S SOMETHING
WE NEEDED TO GO BACK AND REVISIT
AND ONE THING IN PARTICULAR I
THINK THIS IS A SITUATION WHERE
WE OUGHT TO HAVE MORE OF AN
ABILITY TO RECALL GOVERNORS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, JUST AS THEY
DO IN CALIFORNIA.
WHETHER IT RESULTS IN THEM NOT
BEING ELECTED OR  NOT, IT WILL
AT LEAST HAVE THAT THREAT PUT IN
PLACE THAT MAKES THEM THINK
TWICE ABOUT VIOLATING THEIR
RULES IN THESE WAYS.
STEVE: YOU KNOW, BEN I’VE GOT
FRIENDS DOWN IN FLORIDA WHO
SPEND THE SUMMER IN MICHIGAN,
THEY AREN’T GOING BACK, BECAUSE
OF THE RESTRICTIONS THAT WERE
PUT IN PLACE AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE PANDEMIC, WHEN WE DIDN’T
KNOW A LOT, FAST FORWARD WE KNOW
SO MUCH MORE AND NOW PEOPLE ARE
GOING WAIT WHAT EXACTLY DID WE
GIVE HADS AWAY THE KIND OF POINT
THAT YOU MACON THE BEN DOMENECH
PODCAST AVAILABLE AT FOXNEWS